We saw examples of inference attacks.
The two quick examples when
the query was an average of an exam
grade that was authorized but the result
was disclosing somebody's grade,
which we didn't want that to happen.
So obviously, we want to have defenses
against these kind of inference attacks.
These defenses are actually pretty hard.
In general, if you can submit
an arbitrary number of such queries
You can always make an inference based
on the results those queries return.
But there are some things that we
can do to reduce the likelihood
of somebody finding sensitive
information by using such queries
with at least limited amount of effort.
What kind of defenses
can we have in place?
So remember the way we do
these aggregate queries that
are allowed is that the query sort
of says, select a set of tuples.
So, for example, that case we had where
we looking for Junior's standing, we're
going to pull out all the tuples where
the standing attribute value is Junior.
So we're going to pull out
all the tuples that match
this query in some sense.
And then we're going to
aggregate the exam score.
So one way to make sure that
inference is more difficult
is that we don't do that when the number
of tuples that are selected is too few.
The idea here is when it's too few,
extreme case when it's one,
then we know that the average actually
discloses the score that we have.
But if it's a small number of tuples,
the average is going to be close to
the score of every person who is
selected or whose tuples are selected.
So average for a small set essentially
tells us what those values are and
we don't want to do this average
score when the number is too small.
Well you can think of other
cases where if you asking for
some property, and that selected
set of tuples is very large,
then that sort of holds for everyone.
And if it holds for everyone,
then it holds for a given user as well.
So both too small and too large actually
lead to this inference problem.
I'll let you think about
the too large part.
So you should see the aggregation
is happening over a set of tuples.
And does it include every tuple, or
almost every tuple, in the database?
Or, does it include very few?
And depending on the nature of the query
that we have, you may say that,
we can't run that query because
of the number of these tuples,
that it's going to aggregate all.
So that's one way to do that.
The other defense that we
typically do is saying well,
we can transform the database and can
remove all the identifying information.
Think about the exam score
that I was talking about.
Let's say we dropped the student ID and
standing,
even if you're concerned about too few
students with a certain standing, and
then we just post in the exams
score without the names or the IDs.